Hi, welcome to the Anna Ashley Show. I'm Ashley, and I'm Ann, and today we'll be talking about toxic ingredients that may be found in your household cleaners and what you can do to make your own.
But before we get started, please hit the like and subscribe button, and if you're on YouTube, hit the little alert button so you never miss an episode.
So we have a list of toxic ingredients will be running through telling you what they are and the risk that comes along with it.
So obviously here we kind of have a spread of household cleaners, and these are actually ones that when you look at the label, they look healthy.
You know, we're now in toxic, and to better for you, safe.
Yes. So one of the top toxic ingredients that can be found in some of these would be fanlates.
Fanlates can be found in anything that says it has a fragrance in it, which really is just kind of a fragrance.
It's what can be thousands of different chemicals. So you don't really know what that is.
So in fanlates are also found in plastic items, so any type of plastic saran wrap, or plastic bag, or something that can also be found in that, and that can reach into your food.
But the risk with fanlates is that they are an endocrine disruptor.
And again, so you'll just, if you see fragrance on a label, then you know that fanlates are going to be in there.
Trichlessan is also another ingredient commonly found in cleaners.
It's an antibacterial agent, and you know, it's used in antibacterial soaps, antibacterial little hand sanitizers, antibacterial dish washer, dish washing products, face washes, and toothpaste.
And the risk with Trichlessan is that it disrupts the immune system and can disrupt the microbiome because it's an antibacterial.
And then in Canada, it was declared as toxic in 2012, and then in 2017, the US ordered it to be removed from hand sanitizers and liquid soaps, but it still can be found in other products.
And now they're going to call two buttocks, the ethanol.
Perfect.
I think nailed it.
Can we find it in window cleaners?
Window kitchen cleaners and multi-purpose cleaners, and the risk with that is that it is associated with causing lung irritation when inhaled at higher levels.
Malnia is another one that's commonly found in window cleaners, and when you're using something that has ammonia in it, you're going to breathe it in.
You can kind of smell that ammonia smell with windags and those window cleaners.
And if it can cause bronchitis, asthma, lung irritation, all of those, not good types of things.
And just an FYI, if you take ammonia and you mix it with bleach, it can create a poisonous gas. So don't do that.
A healthier choice would be vinegar or vodka.
That's always a healthy choice, right?
Always.
To use as a cleaning product.
Another one is chlorine.
So chlorine can be found in toilet cleaners, white nerves, also obviously found in pools.
It's also used in products that are targeted to remove mold.
And the problem with that is that it can be a skin irritant, can disrupt the respiratory system,
and can potentially cause harm to the eyes as well.
So those are a handful, actually I'm going to talk about some more.
Even more, we have sodium hydroxide, which is going to be found in oven cleaners and drain openers.
This risk is that it can be burning your skin or your eyes as well.
And then inhaling it can create a sore throat.
Then we have sodium lorith sulfate, which is found in laundry detergent, shampoos, hair conditioners, shampoos.
A lot of shampoos and a lot of laundry detergent.
It's a semi-native.
It helps create that cough.
And then body wash as well.
And then it can also be in makeup foundations too.
So that is actually what is found in this product here.
So the risk with sodium lorith sulfate is that it actually is contaminated with a carcinogenic byproduct.
So that's where the harm can be done with that is obviously made in a lab and synthetic.
With this one in particular, it is safer to get it from a plant-based source like coconut oil or a palm oil.
In the ingredient label, it should be in parentheses on where it's coming from.
This one does not have where the source is from.
So that is the difference with that one.
Petroleum disallys is actually in laundry detergents and in softeners as well.
And the risk with this one is with irritant to our respiratory system and potentially to our kidneys.
This can also be contaminated with carcinogen of benzene.
The next one is a cordonary ammonium compound.
That's a big word.
Foulins found in fabric softeners and fabric softener sheets, shampoo, conditioners, and base and body products as well.
This can cause asthma and dermatitis.
So irritation again to the skin.
Other substances in fabric softeners is benzylacetate, which has research into pancreatic cancer.
Benzl alcohol has research with irritated to the respiratory system and then chloroform, which is a neurotoxin and a carcinogen as well.
So big handful of toxins.
So reading your label is important.
Yes, really important.
And not only are ingredients important for ourselves, but they're also important for the environment.
So there's some ingredients that can cause environmental harm.
Palm oil, which can be found in laundry products.
You know, you want to just be aware of how it's sourced.
Palm oil is found in South East Asia in the rainforest.
And when they're harvesting, they're killing the rainforest.
So then it is affecting the orangutans and the wildlife.
So you have to make sure that your palm oil product is from a certified sustainable farm.
For example, an eco-store inductor browners here.
They use sustainably sourced palm oil.
Another one is optical brighteners.
Again found in laundry detergent.
There's risk for toxicity to aquatic life.
And that can cause bacterial mutations in allergic reactions.
And then phosphates, again in the laundry products,
it can stimulate the growth of certain marine plants.
And when they're released into the environment, it can contribute to an unbalanced ecosystem.
So not only are chemicals harming us, they're harming the environment in the eco-system,
which just disrupts the balance.
And this beautiful earth where we have to coexist with all of the living creatures
and we have to be respectful in order to keep them balanced.
Otherwise bad things happen.
Those poor orangutans in eco-system.
I know.
You've got to be mindful.
Yeah, for sure.
Okay, so next we're going to show you how to make a couple of your own ingredients for at home.
If you don't want us to bury labels or it's too overwhelming, you don't want to look for.
So we have what you mentioned is Dr. Bronners, which is something you use all the time,
which is some of that I know of this.
There's lots of ways you can use Dr. Bronners.
This is a great product if you don't want to bury the label.
And the palm oil is sourced from a palm oil farm.
That's the same as the palm oil farm.
Good choice.
Okay.
Then we have these that we use here in the clinic that's diluted with the concentrated household cleaner
and the dish soap as well for these for my own living.
Then we use, we can use vinegar, white.
This is white distilled vinegar.
And we are going to use this for two other things we're going to show you.
So if you have this at home, just don't chuck.
You can make whatever you want.
We have our glass jars.
We'll just put those here.
And then the first one we're going to make is multi purpose spray,
which you don't want to use this one on wood.
So anything else, surface areas, tiles, those would be great.
So, okay.
I need the list here how much to put in.
We're not going to measure accurately because we have limited sources.
Yeah.
Just add volume.
So multi purpose spray.
And it calls for one cup of white vinegar.
And we'll just pour some of that in here.
And then it also calls for one cup of water.
Let's pour some water in there.
I know that you're bringing.
Thanks.
And then we also bring the, what you're going to add into that.
You can leave it by itself as well as if you want to.
Or you can add essential oils that we have here.
So we'll use.
You can use rosemary optional.
Otherwise the tea tree oil here.
So tea tree oil always adds some of that in here.
And then you can add rosemary if you would like to,
which one that since we have it.
It smells good.
Yeah.
It does smell good.
Okay.
So, that is your multi purpose clear.
It smells really good.
It does.
It smells good.
And it's really simple and so simple.
Yeah.
And now you can go clean your entire house with it except for the wood.
And for that smells really good.
It does.
For a glass cleaner.
You're basically going to use the same ingredients.
And we just did different proportions.
So the glass cleaner calls for a half of a cup of water and a fourth of a cup of white vinegar.
So half a cup of water.
Pretend.
Mm-hmm.
Fourth of a cup of vinegar.
And then it calls for four drops of cinnamon, which is kind of interesting.
Cinnamon must have some constituents in it that help, you know, make it so it's streak free.
Oh perfect.
So four drops of the cinnamon.
And then it says you can use peppermint essential oils.
Well, which we have.
Hope that's for those married peppermint.
Oh, maybe we forgot to troupe ground peppermint.
But you can use peppermint as well.
You grabbed a lemon instead.
Which lemon cuts grease.
Yeah.
So four drops of that.
And there you go.
You have your window cleaner.
And I'm not very good at measuring things.
So for this one it called for half a teaspoon of the oil that you use.
I'm sure the brother said that earlier.
Okay.
So half a teaspoon of the essential oil.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know how many drops that is.
Probably like 20 is a teaspoon.
30.
Maybe 30.
30 is a big guess.
So those are your two cleaner options that you can make at your shop at your house.
Or again, you could just buy a simple ingredients.
This laundry detergent was a good find.
Yeah.
Trader Joe's worker uses that one.
So that was a good one we reviewed the label on it.
Again, don't get super beat up about it.
But the safer, the better.
And the less they're the ingredients, the better.
Right.
And this is also from Trader Joe's.
But this has fragrance in it.
And so it's kind of one of the obvious ingredients that we want to stay away from.
So yeah.
So just look at your labels.
So be mindful.
Share this video with friends and family if you felt like it was helpful for you.
Or even just the recipe.
Take home and perform it for your family and see if they even all the difference.
It is much safer for them to inhale the oils than all these chemicals.
And we'll see you next time.
Thank you.
Have fun cleaning.
It's a Hortanger means.
I mean.
Hortanger means.
In the rain.
In my head.
Hortanger means.
In the rain.
In my head.
She got her urine.
Well, that was good.
Laughter healing.
Good for the soul.
The most poor orangutans in the ecosystem.